yeah what's your um
just for to make everyone feel really
bad what's the most money you've ever
made on youtube in a single month
see i got to talk to you after but i'ma
tell you
the most i made was like truthfully
people probably think i made way more i
probably did
because i got like three four that was
like the way they changed up the some of
the youtube programming and yeah but but
but the most you ever got like off of
them
the most that i can say
just off one channel i would say 150.
hey man 150 has a lot 150 000 in a month
yeah
but it it's [ __ ] that make
what's the little kids what's the little
kid's name that opens the ryan's toy
review
i don't even want to know what his [ __ ]
i feel like that you're probably making
like
1.5 million million damn
yeah but at that when you at that point
of making that much money this [ __ ] is
not even exciting no more it's not like
it becomes regular believe it or not
it's like yes between them and some of
these makeup artists my girl be watching
all these damn makeup artists bro
you know kylie jenner made 570 million
this year off omega from what
who the [ __ ] is giving her that much
money that is
crazy i saw that she was the highest
paid like forbes highest paid celebrity
or whatever
yeah i'm finna start selling makeup what
the [ __ ] yeah cause otherwise like what
is what else is she giving to the
marketplace besides makeup
she's just genius she's fighting makeup
she's just a genius these people are
really smart
yeah everybody that's on that list is
just smart that's all it is
because there's so much money out here
don't make no sense you got to pay taxes
if you
know the right [ __ ] do you know the
right [ __ ]
i gotta talk to you after this video
yeah yo well listen
give us a give it give before we wrap
this up because a lot of people man like
look taxes is coming
give some uh some real basic we always
wonder how rich people always don't pay
taxes
can you give us kind of some basic game
on the on taxes like that that you could
kind of like
i mean a little basic game for me just
you live in california
i live here the state tax is [ __ ]
bonkers yeah
you know it is what it is but i just
know that
i just i'm just able to write off a lot
of [ __ ] that's with me because i record
everything
that's my cheat code so like what can
you say it's for video
like i'm writing off this this jewelry
i'm about to go spend 20 000 on the
chain but i'm gonna title the video
i spent twenty thousand on the chain and
then they'd be like
where the [ __ ] does twenty thousand come
from and then you say look
at the videos i literally had to buy it
for the video it's called i suppose
entertainment
that's smart it's investing reinvesting
in myself so i like that
that's actually a nice little gym yes
right now
yo everybody go monetize a youtube
account
right go go start at youtube and when
black friday comes
like rappers can do it too i spent 400
on a tv
right just put it on the internet even
if it has seven views you could be like
yo that was that black friday tv i wrote
that [ __ ] off cuz i got the youtube
video
i'm trying to pop office this content in
this content space
take a picture of that [ __ ] wow
i'm gonna start a whole youtube channel
and no one even knows about where i'm
only posting stuff like
i spent 78 dollars on groceries at robs
and here's the video so i'm writing off
my groceries
yeah whoa my god mrs private zero views
you're very smart show them a screenshot
this guy got the game go go to his only
fans he's not showing his johnson he's
giving you game